[Music]
welcome to our talk so over the course
of the last two days I don't think I've
seen a single presentation that did not
involve communities so at least we'll
fit the profile to introduce us a bit so
Daniel and I I'm Tim and we work for
Gaudi driven it's an IT consultancy
company based in Amsterdam we mainly
focus on big data problems and we kind
of want to help companies use their data
to make decisions so we want to be
data-driven all right
small company and currently we are
situated there so anyone I've been there
this is Schiphol Airport located in
Amsterdam so it's a nice Airport here's
some interesting facts so it's about a
half a million airport movements per per
year lots of passengers and something
that's quite interesting that we didn't
know before we started working at
Amsterdam Schiphol Airport is that it's
actually part of the Royal Chapel group
and it's a hundred percent shareholder
and three airports in the Netherlands
not only that it holds once
approximately 1/5 of the stakes in
Brisbane Airport and much cooler
so who've you flew in on JFK and so we
also did that so terminal 4 of JFK is
the so operating franchise holder is
royal ship whole group that's pretty
cool
Chapel itself is the third busiest
airport in Europe in terms of aircraft
movement and is the busiest aircraft
busiest airport in terms of passenger so
even though we're quite a small country
it's really busy Airport so to get to
our problem statement of the things
we're trying to fix and which is flight
delays we have to get you into what a
turnaround is
so I'd like to focus your attention on
the proper part of the slide which is
top half which depicts everything the
aircraft does from airspace to Airport
and back to airspace so anything that
happens between on blocks and pushback
which basically means you're at the gate
and you leave the gate
that's what concept is a turn around and
many things happen at a turn around
right so we have the passenger of
deboarding boarding
there's the baggage loading and
unloading there's a catering truck which
needs to take care of a few things
there's refueling so all these processes
everything that's happening here
basically the air the airport itself
Schiphol doesn't really know much about
what's happening here so it knows a lot
of things that's happening everything
before that right it knows everything
something in the airspace and knows
what's happening while taxiing it knows
a lot about departing but everything
that's happening a turn around is
managed by the Airlines itself which
means if something happens here the
airport has no idea so they have no idea
which order these things take place in
they have no idea when these happen how
long they take so if refueling happens
five minutes before the flight leaves
you can't imagine that this will lead to
a delay and the airport would like to
know when this is going on so as you can
see here it's less predictable they know
something and it's amazing mainly mainly
because of this beautiful little girl
she lives in E in the control tower she
looks with binoculars and has a look and
see what's going on at every single gate
of the airport so remember this this big
airport we have a control tower right
over there
that's where she's situated she has
binoculars she looks at all these gates
and has to take it have to figure out
which state of the turnaround process is
in as you can imagine that doesn't
really scale very well right so it's
something we need to fix so the thing
that Shippo came up with is basically
very simple let's just put cameras on
the aircraft and front of the gate so we
can monitor everything that's happening
while the aircraft is docked at the gate
so what we want from those camera images
is basically so we'll take a stream of
images a camera feed we need to apply
some magic we have to build and we need
to end up with events all right we need
to know for example when does fuelling
start when is fueling end if you know
when fueling starts you probably can
predict when fueling will end if you
know that you're in some sort of state
and a turn around and fueling hasn't
started yet you could potentially act on
that as an airport so we actually like
to focus on this part this magic system
that we built is actually capable of
spitting out all these events so this is
our magic system we do everything
streaming so we stream in the images
cameras multiple gates multi camp
multiple cameras for aircraft and the
first thing we do is basically a
unification so it means we'll have two
images per gate and when it's unified
into one data data a point in time why
it is important we'll get to that later
after that we do some object detection
so try to see which kinds of objects are
in this data point like is there an
aircraft maybe as their high loader is
there a catering truck and the last part
is once we have the objects we could
potentially generate these
vents so why do we need this so these
are two captures about the camera see
and as you might notice the timestamps
they're pretty close but they don't add
up they don't match both of these images
depict one particular state we turn
around for that timestamp as you can see
there's this really small staircase here
which is an important object that you
can't really see on the left side so you
kind of need both images to tell the
whole state your turn around
and the timestamps don't add up
other than that there's also no ID
there's no foreign key that we can join
on the cameras are not synced up so we
need a way to tell that these images who
come in the stream or basically from the
same same timestamp but could also
happen that one of the cameras drops out
I may only get one image I left all
right maybe both cameras images drop
maybe there's rain on the cameras which
means one of the images is pretty much
useless so we need to take care of that
and the first thing we built a basically
a way of unifying these camera images
into one data point in time so we build
everything in peyten maybe because we
work with data scientists they designed
this kind of like Python so it would be
easy for us to basically map that to
some sort of darker image as having a
Python code putting that in kubernetes
from running it so let's say an image
arrives at time some zero all good
we have another image arriving at time
someone then the matching algorithm
actually takes care it it looks at both
and it figures out okay these are close
enough this is a match I'll combine them
I know I ship them off so let's say a
times some three arrives there will not
be a image for the other camera happens
right then we have a time some six that
arrives and suddenly we have a time some
eight so as you can imagine we have to
queue a bit
so in our streaming engine we have to
queue these images for a while and the
longer you make the queue the more
accurate your matching will be but also
the more delay you will add to your
stream and this is kind of a trade-off
right because you want to act upon your
events as quick as possible if you're
ten minutes late
maybe it's pointless so this is a lot of
playing around with with correct
parameters since there's no match for x
m3
we'll just take x m3 because it's still
valuable valuable information and we
just ship it off to the next step
time some six moves forward in the queue
we figure out that this match we ship
them off so this is basically what's
happening in the unification of the
images which is a very important part
for process so for the next part I'll
hand it over to my esteemed colleague
Daniel who will talk about object
detection and event generation yes thank
you very much Tim so quick heads up
quick disclaimer I'm not a data
scientist so we're not going to be
diving deep into how this entry flow
model works we are going to be looking
at what is it exactly what's it doing
but we won't actually be doing like a
deep dive we are colleagues or data
scientist colleagues have done talks in
the past about this but that's not the
focus of our talk today so object
detection what does this actually look
like and to just to show a real
turnaround what we would have seen if
the video would have worked is basically
a full turn
in this case it was a KLM jet which is
the Dutch national carrier so a lot of
KLM happens and a Schiphol you can see a
couple of things down there on the
bottom and the idea is that again chart
will kind of get generated so as objects
start appearing in this view you'll
actually start generating these
beautiful bars that will show up and
then you can actually see so how long
was the GPU in place which is like a
power unit that they need well they're
stationary because they can't obviously
have their jet engines on permanently
Mulder parked and the same applies for
things like high loaders lavatory trucks
all of those things what you will also
notice and that's why it's a bit sad
that we can't see the video is that a
lot of these things so some things
happen once like say refuelling we'd
expect happen once but some things like
cargo doors opening can happen multiple
times and some of these things should
actually be red flags like if refuelling
happens five times then probably that's
selling air traffic control hey we might
have some technical glitch on this
aircraft this might might give us some
trouble luckily we do have this overview
of some of the objects and events that
we can recognize so I'm not going to go
through each and every one of them but
it is just to show you how much actually
goes on while you're sitting queuing up
at security waiting at the gate to get
on your aircraft all of these things
happen and all of them are arranged by
the airline it will also differ per
airline how exactly these processes work
but it will also differ where the plane
is going how large the plane is all that
kind of stuff how many vegetarians maybe
more onboard whether the catering truck
needs to come twice maybe some special
meals that kind of stuff so there's a
lot of variation and basically the
airport knows nothing so the beautiful
video that we didn't see was all
generated on batch so we started off
just gathering a lot of data from these
cameras that were there and just saying
okay data scientists to go do something
with this data it looks awesome as our
esteemed colleague from NGO data-driven
always tells us batches are for
barbecues we want to do streaming so
this is kind of how we approach getting
a tensorflow model into a streaming
environment which for us was something
new we've never really done before and
we also needed to sort of experiment and
find our feet in how we actually did
have to do
so we actually took a very iterative
approach our initial trial run was
trying to run tends to roll on top of
data bricks so at Schiphol we actually
used it works quite extensively it was
easy the infrastructure was their data
bricks has an ml runtime that works well
nicely you get a lot of packages
pre-installed and the end result was it
worked it wasn't pretty it did kind of
work though we could hook up spark to
Kafka and then streaming from spark into
tensorflow
do the magic that our data scientists
were doing output the results the one
thing we didn't really like about this
though is that it kind of felt like a
square peg in a round hole like we were
using spark because we had to UM data
breaks we weren't actually using spark
because spark so we sort of said okay
but maybe this isn't the right tool so
let's let's try something else
so our second iteration was okay maybe
if we switch to kubernetes we can run
things in docker and in that way
achiever scaling spark obviously is
great for scaling up on larger data sets
and that's something we figured we knew
we would want because at Schiphol there
are about a hundred gates so if you have
to process images every couple of
seconds from every gate you need a lot
of compute and you need to be able to
scale up quickly so our second iteration
was trying tensorflow surfing so who
here has used tensorflow surfing awesome
one guy awesome so ed please correct me
if I'm wrong about this potential flow
surfing is a really easy way to spin up
a API for your train tensor flow model
so you can basically take your frozen
tensor flow graph put it in your docker
image and you'll get a REST API and a G
RPC API for free so it's super super
easy and this was actually where we were
for quite a long time we were quite
happy the biggest downside that we found
is that obviously it being a rests last
year the C API you have to have some
component making the calls all of our
messages all of our images are sent on a
Kafka bus so actually the interface
between Kafka and tensorflow surfing is
a bit awkward we managed to work around
but it wasn't ideal and that sort of led
us to iteration 3 where right now is
let's be dropping tensorflow serving and
just hooking
got directly into tensorflow this also
get was a bit of a hack around we had to
mess around with all sorts of code and
stuff the we had to figure out the
really nice thing about this is the
simplification that we got of our setup
we lost a bunch of components we didn't
have to interact with this API anymore
I've also gained quite a lot of speed
and I'm gonna get to that right now
because anybody here that has ever
worked with deep learning or tensorflow
or anything like that knows as always
this blue pill red pill decision moment
where the blue pill and the red pill are
we're going to say into an Nvidia in
this case please insert your CPU or GPU
manufacturer if you don't like these
ones these were the two options we had
running on the cloud that we were
running on so our data scientist said
yeah yeah we need GPUs we need GPUs as
people actually build a really beefy
physical desktop machine that's SATA
under the desk with five four four
massive GPUs and which was awesome in
the winter because it kept us nice and
cozy in the summer it got a bit hot when
it was like 40 degrees Celsius outside
and then we had this thing with them
training models we actually had a model
freeze we wouldn't let them train models
in the summer because it just wasn't
nice to sit there anymore so us being
dead engineers and not knowing too much
about the internals of these deep
learning models took our day data
sciences were like okay we need GPUs
we'll see if we can get that to work and
we did get it to work but we also kept
an eye on what the cpu performance would
actually be like just to make sure that
we were keeping our options open if we
would need to our results look something
like this so as I said we worked in a
very iterative way iteration one was
okay it worked but I mean that was
pretty much the only upside iteration
two was really a lot better because it
reduced our components it just made it
was a better fit for the problem and
iterations for the three simplified our
set up but also sped us up so you'll
notice an iteration one there's no
difference between GPU and CPU that's
because we actually didn't manage to get
the GPU support working correctly for
some reason
tried we tried to trade what we couldn't
get it to work but I'm about to a
generation too you can see that GPU is
really starting to outperform CPU
iteration 3 is the same you'll notice
that there is no y-axis here we did that
on purpose
because we don't want you to think that
these are in any way scientifically
validated numbers this was us just
running a script using some timing stuff
and then seeing what would happen your
mileage may vary depending on your
machines on how the large the images are
what kind of model you're using this was
just roughly our experience the nice
thing about ending up in this place was
that as you all know GPUs are loved by
all data scientists but not loved that
much by the person that pays the bill
so one GPU and our cloud would cost us
800 euros or dollars a month for the
scale that we were looking at we were
going to need a well quite a few of
these so it was starting to get to the
stage we're like mean these things are
pre pricey so by the time we got the
iteration 3 the nice thing was that we
got our speed on the CPU down to a level
where we went back to the business and
said hey look this is where we're at we
have a GPU which is a factor 10 quicker
roughly we also have a CPU which is
slower but it's also much cheaper what
do you want and so the thing that we
took away from this is we made a
technical problem to use into our Nvidia
to use GPUs of CPUs a business problem
we basically say well it's up to you we
can change the one letter from GPU to
CPU and it's not my problem
just be aware that this is the trade-off
your trading speed for money money for
speed it depends on your use case if we
move on to the final part of our
pipeline we are looking at advent
generation so this is where we're at a
state where we've detected these objects
we've detected two steel trucks high
loaders maybe the the passenger the one
you go through call them the passenger
bridges that will walk in into the
aircraft over so the first time I was
something to our data scientist I didn't
quite understand why we would need this
right I mean we've detected the object
so we're good well it's a bit more
nuanced than that because what object
detection will do is well put this right
and we'll say okay I see an aircraft and
this is the time Sam
it would do this every five seconds own
so if we could give this to your
analysts they'll go crazy they'll just
be like that what am I doing with all
these white noise I'm going to sit
looking at this kind of message for two
hours while the plane is being turn
around yeah the aircraft is there I get
it you know you don't need to keep
telling me so that's where adventure
generation came in and and why we
actually need this so to give you a bit
of an example now I should say before we
start this is a bit of a hypothetical
because we work slightly differently
than this so let's say this aircraft
arrives okay awesome so on the right
down there you'll see this aircraft
present and aircraft absent the two
states and the aircraft can be and right
inside of there or it's not there so
you'll notice we're sliding this blue
box we're sliding this blue box over
this time line which is the x-axis so
the reason we're doing that is we cannot
depend on a single observation from the
object detection model to actually
trigger an event this was also a
requirement from the business that
didn't want any jitters in the object
detection model giving them sort of
white noise the reasons for white noise
can be really diverse so if any if any
of you have ever been to the Netherlands
you know it's quite windy so the cameras
also move slightly when they're up on
there understands we also see sometimes
that aircraft are driving past in the
background it's just no taxing to their
ramp so that could actually confuse the
model a bit and finally and the third
example that Tim just gave in some cases
we also might just not have an image we
might just be missing one of the cameras
so we need to make sure that what we're
seeing are the things that we've seen
actually are sufficient to generate an
event so hence the window so in this
case the aircraft is clearly there we've
also seen in this case where you
actually have seen the aircraft but it's
not quite enough to generate an event
yet we're just going to hold on for a
few more seconds so let's continue the
aircraft keeps on moving now it's firmly
within the window we can see the window
is now fully it's just completely filled
with this airplane so we say okay
aircraft arise this is the time this is
the ramp and this is the airport in our
case it's quite obvious what the airport
be and we do exactly the same at the
other end so the aircraft gets turned
around all of these processes happen in
between and we actually wait until the
aircraft is fully out of the window is
actually completely gone from the ramp
from the gate before generating this
aircraft departs please note that these
are hypothetical events they're not
actual names of the events but this is
the easiest example to give without
having to go into too much technical
detail about how aircraft turnarounds
work so in terms of how event generation
work works we call them
business rules because they're sort of
defined by the business but not really
so we sort of had to figure out what an
actual aircraft departs event would mean
or what a fuel truck departs forming so
this is some pseudocode from one of our
events so I'm going to walk you through
it really quickly so if we look at the
very top we're trying to see should I
generate a and event fuel truck arrives
first step we do is if the fuel truck is
already there that means we've generated
defend before or the aircraft isn't
there we just return immediately don't
care if the fuel truck parks up on our
own ahead of gate for whatever reason
but there's no plane it's not turning
around not interested
next step is super simple what we
actually just start to do is count the
number of trucks that we see in our view
and at the end we just say okay well
what's the ratio how many of the images
do we actually see the fuel truck and
this is also it's a sort of counteract
the effect of may be missing a camera
image for whatever reason maybe the
network was flaky maybe the camera just
blew out whatever and then we just say
well if you know if it's present for
more than whatever we configured it to
be want to say okay the fuel trucks must
be there as I said this is a super
simple super simplified version of what
we actually do we have events that are
much more complicated but you kind of
get the idea which sort of needs to
figure out okay based on the images
based on these detection is it there
should we actually trigger an event
so we've slain quite a few dragons along
the way I think the biggest one was
actually getting tensorflow to run with
kefka it was the biggest challenge but
also the one that in the end probably
was was the most rewarding one
but we do have some other dragons that
we still need to slay
so if you guys have input on this more
than welcome we're very open to it so
the three topics we really still are
thinking about is mobile management how
are we actually going to take this
tensorflow model which consists of this
frozen graph and a label map and make
sure that we can upgrade that we can
rollback if stuff is bad monitor its
performance so right now we're thinking
of something using ml flow with the new
registry but if you have other ideas or
you have bad or good experiences with ml
flow please let us know another thing is
that in our diagram you can really see
we've got a few components so these are
all micro-services in sense and we're
passing messages in between so upgrading
micro-services can be a bit awkward
sometimes especially being making a
graceful and especially when you start
doing schema evolution or start changing
your schema so we're thinking in the
lines of Avro doing something like that
again open to suggestions at a final one
which is going to be the well most
interesting one I would say is right now
we're doing this at Amsterdam's Schiphol
Airport there are some plans to start
doing this at other efforts within the
group and then you start thinking of how
we're actually going to scale this out
from one physical location to multiple
do we need to set up several instances
of the same thing do we use one instance
to use edge computing I don't know we're
still sort of open on that but it's
something we need to start thinking
about we do also have some general
advice things that we learn the hard way
in some cases sometimes the less hard
way and that we just sort of would like
to give it to you as some takeaways so
the first thing is script everything
sometimes it seems like a big investment
to make again it's like oh this is going
to take us a week to build up this
ansible playbook to reconstruct things
it's worth it well every time we build
something like this we were like we
should have done this sooner so the
biggest anecdotal war story here is that
we had a massive outage of our
kubernetes cluster which basically
completely bricked the entire cluster
and it's the Crystal Ike two days to
fully recover their learning point for
us was like okay we need to be able to
do this quicker we don't want to add all
these manual actions all these things so
we build an audible playbook and now we
can
in half-an-hour and that's sort of the
way we try to operate at least the
second one is that it's really important
to iterate so we could have just gone
down the rabbit hole completely on the
data bricks intensive loaf solution that
we had at the very start we probably
would have got it to work but at some
point we also just said say okay it's
okay for now you know this is like pre
alpha version we're good let's just
accept it you don't need to build the
sports car on day one build the
skateboard be happy with the skateboard
enjoy the skateboard we're probably not
even at the sports car yet we're
probably selling the bicycle somewhere
we're happy with the bicycle but if you
have ideas on how to get us onto the
motorbike let us know get people in the
same boat and get them rowing in the
same direction so this is the whole GPU
CPU discussion that we were having
internally as a team and we found it
super valuable once we could actually
bring this to the business and get them
involved because they have valuable
insight but in the end they're also
going to be the people who are using it
so we can be using like technology and
run up huge costs to get sub-second
latency but if they don't care what's
the point it should be their decision in
the end yeah use the right tool for the
right job if you have a screw and you
need to hang up your painting in your
house you can get the screw until your
will with your hammer it's probably not
the best solution it will work just try
to always be critical of the tools
you're using try the sink should I
really be doing this is this really the
way to go so with that that's some of
our general advice we do have office
hours after the break I think because
that's in like a 10-15 minutes please if
you have any more questions or are
interested in hearing more or maybe have
advice some tips whatever come and see
us if there are questions that we can
answer as engineers our product owner
Africa
that's our email address up there so you
can also reach out to her just in case
you want to know more about the project
or how we're going to be doing this so
thank you very much
I know you said it was kind of an
iterative process from curious kind of
what the elapsed time was for like you
know initiation of project and kind of
to get to a couple of those phases sure
yeah so the video that we initially
showed that we didn't show unfortunately
our data scientists had a experiment
week and they built that in a week so
that was just a basic idea like can we
even do this with deep learning with
object detection in terms of actually
getting this pipeline into into
production I think we started in roughly
January February was when we really
started scaling up the team and now
we're in a state we're outputting live
events for a ramp for a game hi thanks
for your talk that was great how did you
manage on how do you manage your
kubernetes
is it cloud-based or as you mentioned we
do have it scripted with ansible or some
other tools I know like cops or
something like this so both actually so
it's cloud-based but we're the kind of
engineers that anytime you click the
mouse we get annoyed so we said okay we
need to be able to do the scripting so
actually with our ansible playbook we
spin up kubernetes cluster or clusters
in in the cloud and what we actually do
is provision the whole thing so storage
credentials everything yeah so the real
so the question is just for the
recording about the what the difference
is between serving and not surfing so
serving is just this super simple layer
that allows us to expose a REST API or D
RPC API yeah that's what you like
so the biggest difference is that you
don't need a separate service that calls
this API that consumes a message from
Kafka and then calls the API way to a
response gets the response puts it back
on Kafka so instead of that we just
stripped away that layer and we just
said okay let's just take this plug and
just plug it straight in where we just
actually get the message and just feed
it straight into the tension flow model
so for us it was a bit of unknown
territory because we weren't that
familiar with tensor fault but it led to
a massive
and it also led to a whole
simplification of our setup in that we
could lose a component we didn't need
this thing calling tensorflow serving
anymore so all in all sensible serving
is really nice it's really awesome to
quickly get something running and I'm
sure there are ways of making it quicker
than what we were doing but for us this
was the this was a nice integration yeah
thanks for the talk that was actually
pretty fun to go through but um I'm
curious did this actually make a
difference like regarding like being
able to you know generate events and
report that to the yeah it's a really
good question it's also something that
for us right now it's a little bit hard
to tell so we've been told that having
this information and having it reliably
it could dramatically reduce delays
mostly because in some cases the example
the Tim mentioned about fuel truck not
being there have known no fuel in the
aircraft ten minutes before departure
that's not something generally now that
the airport even knows so what happens
now is when an aircraft when an aircraft
wants to leave the pilot says hey tower
I'd like to leave but until they get
that coal they have no idea after a
while after it's missed its target
departure time they might say hey guys
what's up
are you're okay so I yeah and I don't
really have an answer for you on that
one how much it's going to make a
difference we hope a lot okay so a quick
question on the end of your pipeline it
seems like you're generating events and
they're coming off going somewhere do
you have another part of the pipeline
that aggravates these for analytics
later as well or is mainly just a place
that this goes off and people can look
at it and real time to determine what's
going on yeah so we actually have a few
so we're data provider basically and we
have a few consumers to consumer data
and one of them is analytics so we
actually sync our data into data bricks
so the analyst can have a look at how
well the events are and how they compare
to the real life data for as far as it's
possible and we have a consumer that
actually tries to make this Gantt chart
that we try to show
which monitors the actual live
turnaround so here we have multiple
consumers over the data a great teaser
for the office hours if you come to the
office hours we'll make sure you can see
the video if you really want to see that
so one more question
adding to the Kafka question before did
you monitor the how the objects are cute
or if you have you know fast enough
tensorflow worker and you know if it's
not gonna failure because of you know
too much - Mattin too much data at the
same time yeah so actually the
prediction so the inference of the
objects is faster than the rate at which
the images arrive so for now we're good
so we do keep monitoring everything
that's happening in a system how long it
takes how much resources they take the
moment that we feel like we're hitting
the max of our infrastructure we need to
scale
[Music]